Daniel Friedman: Hello and welcome.
This is active guest stream number 39.1.
It's March 16, 2023.
We are here with Xu Ji, Eric Elmoznino,
and Guillaume Dumas.
We're going to have a presentation
followed by a discussion action.
So thank you all for joining and off to
you for the presentation.
Eric Elmoznino: All right, thanks.
Daniel?
Yeah.
I'm Eric.
I'm a PhD student in Yoshua Bengio's lab.
Xu: I'm Xu Ji.
I'm a postdoc with Yoshua.
Eric: Yeah.
And we're we're really excited to be
here.
Thanks for the invite.
We're going to be talking about why we
can't describe conscious experiences.
So this is going to be our take on a
really long standing problem in the
philosophy of mind.
But we're going to be looking at it
through the lens of computational
neuroscience and information theory.
So, yeah, hopefully it'll be fun for
everyone.
It mixes a bunch of disciplines.
So I think the most salient way to
illustrate the problem that we're going
to be addressing is to ask you to try and
think about how you would describe the
experience of seeing the color red.
So probably the kind of stuff that's
going in your head is things like, well,
it's a bright, aggressive color
symbolizes love, that sort of stuff.
And in a sense, this is a description.
It's effective.
I would be able to guess which color you
were describing, but in another sense,
it's really inadequate.
Xu: Right?
Eric: If I were blind, for instance, your
description would be totally useless.
I would be no better in understanding
what red looks like.
So there's this real sense in which
conscious experiences are ineffable such
that we can't describe them.
And this applies to percepts like red,
but it also applies to experiences more
broadly.
The experience of having a thought is
just so ineffable, so hard to describe.
And really importantly, this doesn't
happen with most of our knowledge.
I could describe most of what I know
except for experiences.
They have this special place.
So it's a big topic in the philosophy of
mind because it relates a lot to this
thing called the hard problem of
consciousness.
So basically all the hard problem is it's
the problem of how and why physical
processes give rise to conscious
experiences in the first place.
So this is probably the oldest and most
debated problem in the philosophy of
mind.
And it's even led many to the conclusion
that actually we're going to give up.
And consciousness can't be explained with
physical theories at all, that it can't
simply emerge from neuroscience
computation or known physical laws.
So that's a bold statement, and I won't
get into all the details about what makes
the hard problem so salient, but just
here's a few things.
So, first of all, we can logically
conceive of what are called philosophical
zombies.
Philosophical zombies very different from
Hollywood zombies.
They're basically beings that are
physically identical to us.
They behave exactly like us.
In fact, they even have the exact same
neural activity that we do.
But they just aren't conscious.
So similarly, instead of these alternate
agents being unconscious, we could also
imagine them as just experiencing
different things when they're in the same
states.
So for instance, it's conceivable at
least that in an alternate universe, the
same exact brain mechanisms that produce
an experience of red in this world would
instead produce an experience of green in
the other.
And that all experiences would kind of be
like flipped in this way.
So intuitively we think that these two
thought experiments aren't actually
possible in our universe.
But even just their logical
conceivability suggests some kind of
explanatory gap where consciousness
doesn't seem to neatly emerge from or be
determined by physical state or
function.
Another really prominent thought
experiment is the knowledge argument.
And this is the main sort of problem that
our work is going to address.
We're not going to address all facets of
the hard problem of consciousness.
But this knowledge argument is one of the
biggest arguments against physicalism.
So how the knowledge argument goes is
it's another thought experiment.
It asks us to imagine Mary, who has grown
up in a black and white room her whole
life.
And despite this poverty and stimulus,
she actually knows a lot.
In fact, we're going to assume that she
knows all the physical facts about how
color perception works.
So all the relevant physics, all the
relevant neuroscience, et cetera.
And now we're going to ask, well, does
she learn something new when she steps
out of the room for the first time and
actually experiences color?
And if we say that she does learn
something new, which I think is the
intuitive answer, there seems to be a
problem.
We assumed that she knew all the relevant
physical facts about color perception.
So doesn't this mean that what she
learned had to be something that was
nonphysical?
And if there was nothing more to color
perception than physically embodied
information and neural activity, then the
experience is something describable that
she presumably could have read about,
understood, and would have already
known?
So it feels like this thought experiment
really pushes us against physicalism
towards this idea that maybe conscious
experience has something on top of just
information content.
Now of course we don't want to reject
physicalism.
It's been very fruitful for us in the
history of science.
So we really do want to say that
experience just consists of information
that can be described.
So there has to be something wrong in
this knowledge argument here.
And what we're going to do is we're going
to bite the bullet and acknowledge that
experiences actually are ineffable.
So maybe it is the case that experiences
can be described in principle since they
consist of nothing more than information,
but maybe they can't be described in
practice, or at least they can't be fully
described in practice using something
like language.
So then the challenge becomes explaining
why experiences are ineffable under a
physicalist framework.
And that's what our work is really going
to be about.
Xu: Okay, so the structure of the talk is
going to be like this.
I'm going to summarize briefly why
characterizing richness and ineffability
is an interesting and important
question.
Then Eric is going to talk about how
there's a natural correspondence between
ineffability and information loss which
is going to let us link biologically
plausible attractor models of working
memory to ineffability, essentially
because information loss is inherent in
attractive dynamics.
Then I will talk about if you consider
the ineffability of conscious experience
to verbal report as just a special case
of information loss between two specific
points in the communication pipeline,
then you can actually generalize the
notion of ineffability more broadly by
considering, for example, loss from
sensory processing to conscious
experience and even interpersonal
information loss.
We're going to prove, using kilgomero of
mutual information that your conscious
experience being ineffable to another
person implies high cognitive
dissimilarity between the two of you
under our model.
And finally we'll talk about whether an
exact definition of conscious experience
is required at least for characterizing
the nature of ineffability and richness
and also some open questions.
So yeah, why is richness and ineffability
an important question?
There are sort of several reasons.
So first, as Eric said, understanding
consciousness is not just of general
interest.
It's a long standing central problem in
philosophy of mind because it's not easy
to reason about, which has led some
dualists to believe that consciousness
must be at least partly nonphysical in
nature because they can't see how it
could be explained by physical
processes.
But it's also a topic that is of great
interest in machine learning because if
you assume that consciousness is
essential to human cognition, then it
follows that we won't be able to engineer
machines that think like humans without
incorporating consciousness.
We're actually going to argue in this
talk that the confusing aspects of human
consciousness, such as its ineffability
can be understood with information
theory, which, as you all know, is born
from computer science.
We're going to use some primitives from
information theory to shed light on why
consciousness is ineffable and hopefully
to dispel some of the mystery surrounding
it.
Eric: All right, so one of the main
primitives over here that we're going to
use is to talk about attractor dynamics
in the brain and in conscious experience
and how that results in ineffability.
So hopefully this sort of perspective is
familiar to most people.
But we could talk about neural dynamics
by saying the brain has a state at any
particular time and we could denote this
state using a vector.
So for instance, in this plot over here,
maybe we could denote each axis in active
states, each dimension using an
individual neuron.
And maybe we denote the activity of each
neuron using its average firing rate.
So any states at a particular time would
be the firing rate of all the neurons
across the brain.
Now, there's nothing special about
neurons or firing rates.
If you think that things like the synapse
strengths or the dendrite potentials or
the astrocytes or whatever else is also
important to the representation, you
could include those in the state.
They're just additional axes.
The details aren't so important as long
as we have some state that describes what
the brain is doing at any particular
time.
Now, of course, the brain is a dynamical
system.
These states are changing.
So you can think of tracing out
trajectories through state space as a
function of time.
And the way that the state evolves will
be determined just by the recurrent
connections within the brain, as well as
inputs coming from elsewhere.
Maybe we're just talking about the
dynamics within a given brain region.
The inputs would be the other brain
regions talking to it, as well as any
sensory stimulus coming in.
Right?
So this dynamical systems perspective of
the brain has been really instrumental in
understanding the computations it
performs.
And one of the primary methods for
characterizing these computations is to
look at what are called the state
attractors of the system.
And for us as well, state attractors are
going to be a really important part of
our ineffability framework in a bit.
So basically what an Tractor state is, is
it's a state where once the system
reaches it, it's going to remain there at
least until inputs come in and change the
dynamics or noise, not just the state out
of this attractor.
So you can see this thing clearly within
the figure.
The X and y axis over here are like the
state of the brain.
Again, maybe something like the average
firing rates of the neurons.
These arrows are illustrating the
dynamics of the brain.
So how the state will evolve given the
brain's connectivity, given the
synapses.
And you can see that there's some regions
where all the arrows, all the dynamics
kind of contract to a single point.
So that's called a fixed point.
If it's one dimensional, it's a kind of
state attractor.
And because all the arrows point towards
it, once you finally reach that state,
you're not going to move out again until
the dynamics change, because inputs came
in or until noise nudges you out.
And you can see that each state attractor
also is associated with this sort of
attractive region, an attractor base in
its cults, where once a trajectory is
somewhere in that region, it will
eventually converge to the attractor
again in the absence of noise.
So these attractors are really common in
the brain and also in artificial
recurrent neural networks trained on
tasks.
And a big computational benefit is that
they provide a form of transient memory.
Once you're in the attractor, you remain
there, that's where the memory comes in.
And because of this and other benefits,
they're implicated in a wide variety of
neural processes like working memory,
long term memory, decision making and
higher level cognition and we'll argue
consciousness in general.
So they're all over the place in the
brain.
An additional aspect of them that's
interesting and it's going to be relevant
for our talk, is that you can think of
attractors as having a sort of dual
discrete and continuous nature.
So what I mean by that is that the
discrete aspects of an attractor is given
by the fact that there's a finite number
of them and that attractors are mutually
exclusive, right?
You're in one or you're in another.
So this means that we could use discrete
symbols to denote which attractor the
system is in.
There's a finite number of them, you're
either in one or another.
And this basically lets us identify or
label the states using a discrete
variable.
There's also a notion though, in which an
attractor is just a continuous high
dimensional vector in this really high
dimensional state space of the brain,
right?
Every attractor basically is just a
vector in state space.
And that means that they're not
arbitrarily discrete states, they have
continuous representations.
We can say, for instance, that one
attractor is more or less similar to
another one depending on how close they
are in state space.
And that gives a representation to the
attractors that's the high dimensional
sort of continuous part.
So just to recap, discrete part is you
could identify which attractor you're in
in the finite set of all possible
attractors.
But you could also talk about an
attractor through this continuous high
dimensional vector that describes where
the attractor is in the high dimensional
state space of the brain.
And to wrap your head around this,
there's a good analogy to word embeddings
in NLP.
So in NLP each word has a discrete ID
that's like the symbolic discrete part,
but also each word is associated to a
high dimensional vector that gives it a
representation sort of the meaning of the
word, where we could say that words are
more or less similar to each other.
Okay, so we're going to use attractor
dynamics quite a bit to explain a
significant source of ineffability in
conscious experience later.
But for that to be relevant, I first need
to spend a bit of time to convince you
that neural dynamics that produce
conscious experience actually do have
attractors.
And for this there's already a lot of
work in the literature connecting
attractors to conscious experience.
So this part is not something new from
our work.
So for instance, one of the leading
theories of consciousness, which is the
global workspace theory, actually
implicitly implies that attractor
dynamics are kind of fundamental.
So what global workspace theory says is
basically like across the brain in all
the different regions, you have sort of
sub process worker, workers basically,
and these different distributed
mechanisms, they can't speak to each
other very easily.
They mainly communicate through this
global workspace just kind of like a
bottleneck.
Think of it like a blackboard that all
the different processes across the brain
could write to.
You could also think of it as like the
ram of the brain, but basically it's
collecting information from the different
workers.
And one key aspect about the global
workspace that's posited in the theory is
that for content in the workspace to then
be broadcast to the subprocesses, for
instance, for us to be able to talk about
what's in the workspace for it to be
written to kind of speech regions.
The content of the workspace has to be
amplified and sustained for a certain
amount of time.
It has to be stable, basically.
And this is clearly where the attractors
come in, right?
Attractors by definition are these states
that are stable, these states that are
sustained.
So basically what global workspace theory
says is that the context of the global
workspace that can be used by the rest of
the brain are the attractor states.
And the relevance to consciousness in
this theory is that it posits that the
contents of this global workspace are the
things that we're aware of, the things
that we're able to report, the things
basically that we're conscious of.
And then just kind of like
terminologically.
Another term for this workspace is called
working memory.
The idea there, it's a sort of like
really short term memory in the sense
that you could quickly act on the things
that are in this global workspace or
report on them.
They're accessible, basically.
Okay, so that's one very powerful
argument for why attractors are relevant
to consciousness.
There's a bunch of other related
arguments.
For instance, just introspectively you
could think of what experience is like is
a sequence going from one thought to the
next to the next.
We kind of have this like a sequence of
discrete events.
And that clearly looks like a dynamical
system, kind of jumping between attractor
states and then experimentally.
There's also been work showing that in
psychology experiments, when you sort of
present a stimulus to a subject and you
vary the amount of time that the stimulus
is presented to kind of bring it below or
above the conscious threshold.
Well, in the conditions where subjects
report being aware of the stimulus, the
main thing that's different is that the
representation is really stable and
robust and noise.
And those are also clearly properties of
attractors.
Xu: Okay?
Eric: So again, I'll use those attractors
to identify a source of ineffability in a
little bit.
But first I need to also introduce how
we're going to formalize the very notion
of ineffability.
And for this we're going to use
information theory part Shannon
information theory.
I'll do that now and then she will talk a
bit about Kamagrav complexity as another
formalism.
But hopefully most people are familiar
with this.
But one thing that we're going to be
using is the entropy of a state.
So for instance, if you have the entropy
of some random variable X, to make things
concrete, maybe that random variable is
conscious experience.
So the entropy of conscious experiences,
that value would be high if the
distribution over conscious experiences
was kind of diffused.
Andy Clark so there's equal probability
for all possible experiences, and entropy
would be low if the distribution over
conscious experiences was peaky.
So that's kind of like the green
distribution in this image would have low
entropy and the red distribution that's
sort of flatter and more uncertainty
would have higher entropy.
And basically what entropy is going to
quantify in our framework is the richness
of a variable, in particular the richness
of conscious experiences.
Why this is a good measure of richness is
because if conscious experiences could
kind of take on many possible values with
equal probability, they're very kind of
diverse in that sense, well, then it's
something that's rich.
Some other notions that are going to be
important are mutual information.
So here that's denoted by I of x and Y.
And what that denotes is how much shared
information there is between two random
variables.
So again, to make things concrete, x we
could take to be a conscious experience,
whereas Y, maybe that's a description of
the experience, maybe a verbal
description.
So in this case, the mutual information
will be really high if the verbal
description uniquely determines the
experience.
So basically, another way of saying that
is knowing the verbal description.
We have no more uncertainty about what
experience is going on.
They perfectly determine each other.
So that would maximize the mutual
information.
And in contrast, if the message told you
nothing about the conscious experience
and you were just as unsure as when you
didn't have the message, well, then the
mutual information would be zero.
This is useful because we could use it to
define a notion of ineffability.
So this conditional entropy that we've
written h of X, given Y is equal
basically to the richness of X.
So the entropy of a conscious, of
conscious experiences minus the mutual
information between conscious experiences
and other variables like their
descriptions, that's the mutual
information.
What this captures basically is how much
information is lost when going from an
experience X to a description Y, right?
If all the information was lost, if Y
doesn't tell you anything about X, the
mutual information is zero, and H of X,
well, the conditional entropy will be
equal to the richness of X.
If Y perfectly determined X, well, then H
of X and the mutual information cancel
and the conditional entropy would be
zero.
So what conditional entropy describes
basically is how much information is lost
when moving from X.
So like a conscious experience to Y, a
description of it.
And that's, that's a perfect description
of what ineffability is intuitively,
right?
It's how much information is is lost when
I try and describe something like an
experience.
Okay, so I think we have most of the
background out of the way, and now we're
ready to describe one main source of
ineffability that arises due to attractor
dynamics.
So very quickly to describe some, some
variables over here that we're going to
be using throughout the presentation.
If you look at that top right diagram,
we're going to have X, which is basically
the trajectory of neural activity that's
relevant for a conscious experience.
So for instance, in Global Workspace, x
would be the trajectory of the working
memory state.
We're going to assume that the trajectory
of neural activity produces a conscious
experience.
We're going to be calling that conscious
experience S throughout.
But also the trajectory importantly is
going to follow attractor dynamics so
they converge to states such as so how
does this result in ineffability?
Well, basically the idea is that whenever
you have attractor dynamics, there's a to
one mapping from trajectories to
attractors and this induces information
loss, right.
Just knowing the attractor, we're not
able to kind of go the other way around
and infer what the original trajectory
was.
So this conditional entropy, this
ineffability of X given A is going to be
high, basically.
All right, why does this matter?
Who cares if there's information lost
between the trajectory of working memory
and the attractors that it converges to?
Well, important thing here again is that
Global Workspace postulates that for
working memory content to be accessible
across the brain, it needs to be
amplified and maintained over a
sufficient duration, so thought to be
around 100 milliseconds.
So this means that working memory is
going through these trajectories X, but
only A, only the attractor can be
reported and only the attractor could
broadly affect behavior.
Only it could be written to memory, only
it could be broadcast to these other
processes.
So that means that the contents of
working memory, kind of these transient
contents in the trajectory, X are
inherently fleeting.
There's rich information that was encoded
in the moment, in the moment of the
trajectory, but that can't later be
recalled or reported because only the
attractors can be recalled or reported
and kind of if we zoom out and go back to
our philosophical notions of
ineffability.
This also explains why it's difficult to
sort of catch yourself in a thought.
Right.
Working memory encodes these rich and
subtle thoughts through the trajectory,
but we can never quite pinpoint or report
in words what those thoughts consisted
of.
Were they verbal?
Were they pre verbal?
Did they consist of visual imagery?
It's really hard to say exactly.
And the reasoning would be that, well,
there's just a lot of information that's
lost going from these trajectories to the
attractors that again we could report on
or that we could recall or they could
just broadly affect behavior.
So that's one huge source of ineffability
arising from attractor dynamics in
working memory.
Now these attractor dynamics also give a
lower bound for ineffability during
verbal report.
So now at the top right, I've added
another variable, M.
That's basically some verbal message that
you could be using to describe your
experience.
And M is a function of the attractors,
right.
According to global workspace, only the
attractors can be reported on or used
across the brain.
So this means that basically, the
ineffability of an experience given a
verbal message has to be at least as
great as the ineffability given an
attractor, because M is a function of the
attractor and you can't gain information
when applying a function, you can only
destroy it.
But we're actually going to argue that
the ineffability is not just lower
bounded by the ineffability of the
attractor, it's actually, in practice,
quite a bit greater than that.
And the reason is that M, this message,
is a discrete variable, right?
It's language, whereas A, the attractor
is this really high dimensional snapshot
of some cortical states.
So because of the asymmetry between the
richness of these variables, there has to
be information loss.
And intuitively, what's going on here is
that you can think of there as being a
many to one mapping from attractors to
messages as well.
So for instance, if I say that I saw fat
cats, that paints a picture.
But it's also leaving out significant
details about the original attractor,
which presumably encoded things that you
were aware of, like the cat's color,
size, pose, the background, all these
things that you were aware of and that
were encoded in the attractor.
But you can't really put into a message
without it being prohibitively large.
So again, the idea here is that the
ineffability of experiences given
messages higher than given attractors,
because the message divides the space of
attractors more coarsely, it's a simpler
variable, it adds additional information
loss.
So one problem is, if language is so
coarse and simple, why can it describe
experiences at all?
And the solution is that while attractors
and the message kind of both share this
discrete part, right?
So the message, because language is
discrete, can be used to index or
identify compositional attractors.
There's this comparable richness
basically between the message and the
discrete part of the attractor.
Which means that in practice, the
richness of the experience h of S is
typically much greater than the
ineffability of the experience given the
message.
So that explains why we still can
communicate somewhat with language, even
though it's this really low dimensional
simple thing.
So, to recap quickly, what we have over
here is the argument that the detractor
dynamics are empirically ubiquitous in
neural activity across brain regions.
They've been proposed as a computational
model for working memory.
And prominent models contends that
conscious experience is a projection of
working memory states.
And one of our key contributions is to
connect these theories to argue that
attractor models, working memory offer an
account for the ineffability of conscious
experience, because attractor dynamics
induce significant information loss.
That's the general argument.
There's one quick thing to add over
here.
So I've been talking about working memory
a lot less about conscious experience so
far.
So let's link the two.
What's going on over here is that there's
many ways to link conscious experience to
X to working memory, basically.
And there's kind of two main options.
So one is we could say that the
instantaneous state of working memory is
always conscious.
So all the states in between attractors
are also consciously experienced.
And how attractors would result in
ineffability.
Here is that, again, what you're able to
recall, what you're able to report is
just the attractor, not the actual
experiences in between attractors that
you were having.
But there's another possibility, which is
to say, well, maybe only the attractors
themselves are experienced.
However, importantly, ineffability exists
regardless in this case, right?
If only A is conscious, a can still
encode the fact that there's information
lost during processing.
And working memory during these
trajectories.
Information loss is something that is
computable.
It could be encoded along some dimensions
in the attractor, for instance, which
explains how we could be consciously
aware that there's information lost
during working memory processing.
Okay.
Xu: Yeah.
So now I'm going to talk about
generalizing ineffability.
Once you view ineffability as information
lost from a source variable to a
destination variable, then there are a
myriad of different pathways that you can
characterize, which we're going to split
into two groups.
So pathways confined within an individual
or intrapersonal communication, and
pathways that extend between individuals
or interpersonal communication.
So in the intracase, you've already seen
conscious experience, the working memory
trajectory, the attractive state, and the
message.
But you can also consider D, which is the
input data to the system, and V, which we
use to denote the state of processes
considered outside the delimitation of
working memory.
And you can also consider the cognitive
parameters of the individual being
communicated to.
So we're going to work with Alice and
Bob, and we're going to assume that Bob
has a brain which is structurally
identical to Alice's but has different
parameters phi, tilde instead of phi.
And we're going to denote Bob's cognitive
state using the tilde.
So empirical evidence from neuroscience
suggests that the brain is hierarchical
in nature, and there are many levels of
organization, many instances of active
dynamics across organizational levels and
cortical regions.
So one example is the inferior temporal
cortex is a sensory processing area that
responds discriminatively to novel
sensory stimuli, whereas the prefrontal
cortex, or PFC, appears to be implicated
in maintaining the attention modulated
representations of working memory.
And to a first approximation, in this
simple model, it's easy to obtain the
result that richness of one process
constrains the richness of another.
So here we have that richness of working
memory trajectories.
Hx is upper bounded by the richness of
its inputs.
And subsequently, we also have that the
richness of conscious experience, HS is
upper bounded by the richness of
conscious experience and the richness of
subprocess states.
Now we're going to zoom out and consider
the interpersonal communication case.
Shannon entropy has some drawbacks when
it comes to characterizing interpersonal
ineffability.
A major one is that Shannon entropy.
Assumes you have access to Phi, Alice's
cognitive parameters.
So note that H phi S given m, for
example, is the descriptional complexity
of S given not just A, but also phi.
And since we can't assume in the
interpersonal case that Bob has access to
Alice's brain parameters, we're going to
rely on the Kulgamarov framework for
information theory.
If you're unfamiliar with the kilgomera
of complexity, the first thing to note is
that conglomerate complexity, or Kx, is
defined on instances X, hence the
lowercase rather than variables, which
are noted by capitals.
Kx is roughly defined as the length in
bits Lz of the shortest binary program Z
that prints x and Holtz.
So there's no explicit dependency on the
probability distribution over X, unlike
in Shannon information.
But we can introduce PX by taking an
expectation over the cogomera of
complexity of state to obtain the
cogomerav version of Shannon entropy.
And likewise for ineffability, we
characterized it before using conditional
entropy.
In the Kogamara framework, expected k of
x given y is sort of the analog to shadow
unconditional entropy, and that
represents the length of the shortest
program that prints X, given that you
know Y or that y is accessible to your
program.
And it's approximately equivalent up to
logarithmic terms to kx minus IX, where
IX colon y is kilgomer of mutual
information, which can be interpreted as
the difference in program length for
printing X depending on if you know Y or
not.
Roughly speaking, there are a lot of
similarities between Shannon information
and Polgamorov information.
For example, mutual information in both
cases is maximized if X is equal to y in
the Shannon case, because that means Y
uniquely determines X, and in the
Kogamarov case, because it means that
given Y, you don't require any extra bits
to print X.
In fact, if you assume knowledge of the
probability distribution P, then expected
cogmera of complexity and Shannon entropy
are equivalent up to some constant
factor.
Because it turns out that the most
efficient way to describe a state X on
average, given that, you know, the
distribution, is to encode X with a
description of length minus log PX.
This.
But if you don't know the distribution
which we want to make use of in the
interpersonal case, because the
parameters of the speaker's brain are not
given, then the higher the descriptive
complexity of that unknown distribution,
then the higher the ceiling on active
inference between expected cognitive
complexity and Shannon entropy.
And in our case, we'd expect that to
apply because the space of cognitive
states is enormous, the probability
distribution over those states is very
complex, and the states themselves are in
general complex to reconstruct being very
high dimensional vectors.
The second advantage of Kogama of
complexity, in addition to allowing us to
explicitly avoid conditioning on the
probability distribution, is that Shannon
entropy is a measure of statistical
determinability of states as opposed to
difference in unique states.
So in Shannon information, entropy is
fully determined by the probability
distribution on states, and it's
unrelated to the meaning or structure or
content of the states.
Whereas cogmera of complexity is
concerned with the difficulty of
reconstructing states I e absolute
difference, which corresponds more
closely to the lay definition of
ineffability.
Here are a number of results that we
include in the paper.
So the first one is quite simple.
You can't increase cogmerate complexity
by conditioning on more states, because
the program can simply choose to ignore
the input if it doesn't help to shorten
the length of the program.
So we have trivially that KS given m, the
complexity of conscious experience given
the message is at least as great as KS
given m and p phi.
But you would expect this gap to be quite
significant because of the complexity of
p phi.
In our case, and generally in non toy
cases, the probability distribution
itself provides a lot of information.
So it significantly reduces the
descriptive complexity of S if you're
able to condition on it.
This first result illustrates essentially
the difference in ineffability from the
tabular raza case on the left, where you
don't condition on Alice's brain
parameters phi, to the case where you can
assume access to Alice's brain
parameters, which is analogous to the
Shannon entropy characterization that
Eric was talking about.
But the quantity that we're more
interested in is this expression in the
green box.
So K s given M and P tilde phi, which is
the expected ineffability well, in
expectation of Alice's experience s given
the message and Bob's brain parameters
tilde phi, you can show that this
quantity is upper bounded by an
expression that scales with KP phi given
tilde phi, which is a measure of the
cognitive dissimilarity or the
descriptive complexity of Alice's brain
given Bob's brain.
So, in other words, if your experiences
are ineffable to someone I e, the left
hand term in the green box is high.
That implies that your brains are highly
behaviorally dissimilar under our model.
So we can use this result to provide an
account for what Mary learned when she
stepped out of her black and white room.
And essentially what it's saying is that
neurotypical Alice's experience of color
is ineffable to Mary, which implies that
they are cognitively dissimilar.
And cognitive dissimilarity is not the
same as knowledge inadequacy, because
knowing how the brain should respond to a
particular stimulus is not the same as
being able to execute that response when
you're actually exposed to the stimulus.
So the cognitive dissimilarity principle
is something that we generally believe
intuitively, but it's also been studied
in neuroscience.
So the ability for the neural activity of
two brains to synchronize, which is to
say, to behave in a mutually determined
manner, appears to facilitate
communication between individuals.
There's also a connection to theory of
mind, which is the skill of being able to
infer the thoughts of others.
So if Bob's cognitive functions, FX and
FS, which produce his working memory
trajectory and his conscious experience,
are optimized for decoding Alice's
message m into her conscious experience
s, then ineffability is reduced.
If bob's conscious experience s tilde is
conditioned on compared to m because it
implies that part of the computation of
reconstructing s is executed during
inference of tilde s meaning that the
smallest program from tilde s bob's
conscious.
Experience and tilde phi Bob's cognitive
parameters to s.
Alice's conscious experience would make
use of tilde s to reduce the sort of
residual work that needs to be the
residual information that needs to be
supplied in order to determine s, which
would shorten the descriptive length of
that program.
So, in other words, making progress at
inferring the conscious experience of
others in your own cognitive processing
could literally be interpreted as
reducing the ineffability of their
conscious experience.
Quickly, we're going to touch on the
grounding problem.
So, as Eric mentioned before, two
individuals will generally understand the
same word or sentence in different ways.
And our measure of ineffability does
capture this dissonance for two reasons.
And first, measures of ineffability, such
as we saw in the previous slide, they are
bound by a ceiling that scales with
cognitive dissimilarity or the cogmera of
complexity of PFI given p, tilde Phi.
And phi includes all the parameters in
Alice's computational graph, including
those that parameterize functions defined
on the input data D.
And likewise for Bob.
So that means that Alice's parameters,
phi are grounded in a representation that
is at least partly shared with Bob's
tilde phi.
So if Bob's parameters implement a
function that operates differently on
input data compared to Alice, then they
do not inform on each other to a great
extent and the ceiling on ineffability is
increased via this KP phi given p tilde,
phi tan and secondly, conscious
experience s is a function of phi.
It's computed using a function that
depends on phi.
And likewise for Bob and phi contains
Alice's long term knowledge.
Therefore, S is capable of containing
information about the assumptions that
Alice makes in the process of generating
her conscious experience and that's
included in the reconstruction target of
KS, which is to say the description or
complexity of her conscious experience.
So, our model offers an interpretation
for the observations of Sperling, which
were made in 1960 in this very famous
experiment where he showed subjects a
grid of characters briefly and then asked
them to recall a specific row.
He observed that subjects were generally
able to report the prompted row
accurately, but not all the characters in
the grid, despite being able to report
that they had a conscious experience of
they consciously apprehended all
characters in the grid.
And our model offers an account for this
this phenomenon in in the following way.
So upon being exposed to the grid of
characters and being prompted to report
the characters in a specific row, working
memory contents represented by the
attractive state A presumably contains
the identities of those four characters
in the prompted row as well as a summary
over the grid.
For example, the approximate number of
characters or their agreement and an
estimate of the information lost by that
summary.
Whilst information sufficient to
discriminate all characters would exist
at some point in the computational
pipeline, but primarily in upstream
sensory state V from which working memory
trajectory X and working memory output A
are computed.
Subsequently, since the active states A
is directly accessible to verbal
reporting processes, the characters of
the prompted row, the grid details at
summary level, and the presence of
information loss would be directly
reportable, whereas full grid details
wouldn't.
And note that this explanation would hold
irrespective of where the distinction
between conscious and unconscious is
drawn.
So whether X the working memory
trajectory, which may contain sufficient
information to discriminate all
characters or not, whether X is
considered conscious or not.
So, as this suggests, one of the points
that we make is that at least when it
comes to characterizing richness and
ineffability, the exact definition of
what constitutes conscious experience.
So the definition of FS phi in the
computational pipeline is not that
important.
We utilize this minimal computational
model without relying on the
implementation details in order to allow
us to make general statements about
richness ineffability.
And as Eric hinted before, you can
account for the report of the report of
ineffability from this computational
assuming this computational graph,
irrespective of how you define FS.
So if X is considered to be conscious,
then the attracted dynamics bottleneck,
the amount of information accessible to
working memory output and verbal report.
But if X is not conscious, then
information lost during processing can
still be reported on.
It can still be approximately computed
and reported on, leading us to report on
ineffability.
So finally, some future directions for
this work.
One of them is to link it to the
neuroscience.
So, for example, to actually get some
empirical estimates of the amount of
information lost using neural correlates
of working memory state, for example.
And also, I think for a deeper
understanding of consciousness, you have
to consider why it exists and not just
how it manifests.
So this is something that we don't touch
on on the paper.
But the use of information bottlenecks in
machine learning would suggest that
information loss actually has a purpose.
And specifically the purpose is
generalization.
It improves the robustness of functions
learned from data to noise, and it
improves the ambiguity of functions to
perform optimally on inputs that were not
seen during training, which is what
generalization is defined by.
And this is important because if we want
to incorporate sort of observations about
consciousness into our artificial models,
what we really want to capture is the
benefit that consciousness affords
biological models.
And we might not need to transfer the
actual form that it takes in human
cognition and that's it.
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you for the presentation, Kiom.
It would be awesome if you could give
some opening remarks and then we can have
a discussion and hear any questions from
the live chat.
Guillaume: Sure.
Well, thanks again for the invitation to
mind jazz on these beautiful topics.
So as opening questions and discourse, I
would say, like a strong message here is
that through the formalization that was
just presented, we have an account that
allowed to make the bridge between access
consciousness and phenological
consciousness.
Something that was described very well in
the paper that was cited of the Nakash in
Philosophical Transaction B, how you
don't necessarily need something more
than access consciousness to account for
these phenomenal aspects, but it's also a
lot of open questions.
Like typically we have seen how there is
an information loss within brain and
between brains, but we can also
complexify the within brain message
passage, for instance adding
metacognition.
So at mida we are also working on
addition of cognitive architecture on top
of global neural workspace with typically
attention schema theory for Michael
Garciano.
And so there is again in these meta
representational steps a lot of
information as well.
And I think from an empirical point of
view at both behavior and
neurophysiological level, there is also a
lot to unpack there on how our
metacognitive representation of ourselves
is also impoverished information from the
real states that occur underlying and
that connected well with the social
dimension of consciousness.
And here we tapped a bit on that with the
ineffability at the interpersonal level.
But in the case of the attention schema,
there is a very interesting reversal from
evolutionary standpoint of why the brain
comes up to represent others at first and
then we are recycling the neural
mechanisms to predict others behavior on
ourself.
And there is a kind of flipping of the
traditional narrative in cognitive
neuroscience with Graziano because the
others come first in a way and self
consciousness become a sort of side
effect of having to have all the
mechanisms to deal with others.
And here we don't talk too much about the
representation of the self, but I think
it's a very interesting path following
this work.
Then there is also something that we
didn't discuss too much, but we think
about the trajectory to the attractor and
how many trajectories can lead to one
attractor.
But interestingly, from a sequence of
attractor you can recover sort of a
trajectory.
So like if I have point A and point B and
point C, by having the sequence IBC, I
will tend to have a trajectory that looks
alike each time.
And so it's kind of heading towards like
the dynamics also of social interaction
and culture.
So typically cultural artifacts like
music or movies are eliciting stuff from
a subjective experience that seems like
stronger than just words, I'm saying
stronger than words, but even words are
sequences.
So in a way there is maybe in the
dynamics of communication a little bit of
information that is retrieved by the
interpolation of different discrete
states of different attractors.
It's in the inequality that we saw.
The inequalities are there, but maybe we
can play a bit with those phenomena to
see to what extent we can retrieve more
information by playing on those dynamical
phenomena in communication and regarding
communication.
So we talked about the grounding problem
and how the message and the attractors
are kind of aligned between people
through a shared statistical
environment.
And I think the Kolmogorov framework is
interesting in the sense of a generative
model of the world that you have to share
with others.
In a sense, I'm working a lot on autism
and I'm interested in neurodiversity.
The fact that you have this
dissimilarity, the cognitive
dissimilarity in the information loss, is
also very interesting to interpret how
diversity at the biological level can
have an impact on how certain people
would have more difficulty to communicate
with others.
Specifically in a neurotypical world.
Like, we have a society that is very
normative in design for neurotypical.
And so people who are more outside the
norm and are more neurodiverse would then
have more difficulty to align their
genetic model and communicate with
others.
That's also something that would be nice
to discuss or to explore later.
And finally, so since we are on an active
active inference Livestream, I would take
the occasion to mention how it could
connect with active inference.
We didn't really talk about the active
inference formalism in the paper, but
typically I'm coming back from a workshop
on computational neurophenology where we
used the previous work of Varela on
neuroscience and phenology to try to have
a generative passage between first person
and third person experience.
And we discussed during the whole week
how computational models can be a third
constraint to stabilize this relationship
between first and third person
perspective on consciousness.
And I was among the rare people there not
completely convinced by active
inference.
And I was like trying to argue about the
need for plurality at the formalism
level, even from a theoretical
perspective and for plurality in those
domain, but at least from a formal point
of view, to try to not bet all our eggs
in the same basket, so to say.
And here it's a very nice example how
even you can combine formalism that were
mutually exclusive in the literature.
So for typically coming more from the
embodied cognition and variables work,
people with embodied cognition work tends
to be more in dynamical system theory and
very opposed to computationalism and
information theory.
Here we show in this paper that
information theory and dynamical system
theory can totally work hand in hand.
So it doesn't mean that we need to commit
to one or to have all formalism.
But to maintain this plurality, I think
is very important from an epistemological
standpoint and still the connection with
active inference, that could be
interesting.
And that's one of the things that I kept
from last week workshop, is how from a
social interaction point of view
synchronization.
And I worked a lot on intervention
synchronization and those phenomenal
synchronization can be optimality for
information transfer, as we see here.
But in the context of active inference,
it's also the optimal minimizer of free
energy because you have the two
generative models that are perfectly
aligned and so you don't have error in
your prediction because the other person
become a mirror of your own generative
model.
So that may be also some bridges and
predictions that can show that those
different formattems are multiple way of
looking at the same thing.
Daniel: Thank you.
Awesome points.
So feel free to discuss if you have any
responses and just take it from there.
Eric and shoe.
Or I can ask some questions or read some
comments.
Do you have any comments on Guillum's
thoughts?
Xu: Yeah, I think we have some.
Do you have things to say?
Eric: Go first.
Xu: Yeah, that was a long list of
comments.
I find your comments about the autism
link really interesting because actually
that's pretty much directly what the
message of the result is, is that
cognitive dissimilarity is associated
with difficulty in communicating.
So yeah, actually the last thing that you
said about how if the communicator and
the listener's brains are synchronized or
if they're equal, there's no prediction
error, that's kind of the machine
learning problem, actually, as a whole.
I don't know if this is a big thing, but
the whole point of machine learning is to
discover the true model that you're
trying to learn so that you have no
prediction error.
Right?
So, yeah, I dean, so I'm not an expert on
active inference by any means.
But one thing that does make me a bit
like apprehensive about it is that it's
so concerned with prediction.
Generative models are about
reconstruction and prediction, whereas
cognition is about survival, and
prediction is part of survival.
Obviously.
I mean, you need to be able to predict, I
don't know, not crashing into a car or
something so that you don't die, but it's
just a part.
And more generally, the inference of
cognitive states in the brain is not
about discovery of truth in some sense,
you know, it's not about coming up with
with true model or explanation for some
phenomenon.
It's about sort of optimizing for your
fitness.
So, yeah, that's something that I don't
quite understand, sort of what the active
inference perspective on that would be.
I don't know if Daniel, you had some
comments or not.
Daniel: Okay, just jumping with active
inference and then I'll give more
comments in the chat.
But I think that's a great set of
points.
So if I can make one point to Guillaumes
first.
You spoke about in the presentation the
generalized ineffability, and it reminded
me of a few times in active inference
where we're hearing about generalized
synchrony, generalized, which means like,
not necessarily lockstep or mirror, but
mutually information encoding and not
necessarily linearly correlate and
synchronize, like the end state of the
metronomes.
But there's like complex information
transfer, especially in this multi scale
setting, generalized synchrony, which is
enabled by the generalized coordinates,
which are the coordinates of motion of
the path.
So these are kind of the summary
statistics to describe the Taylor series
expansion around that path or to better
describe that path taken in some way.
And generalized homeostasis, which for
certain environmental regularities it may
be sufficient to be entirely retrodictive
or there may be physical or cyberphysical
constraints so that you'll have a system
that is purely designed a different way.
So I wouldn't say any theory is
necessarily too opinionated with respect
to what you could describe.
And I think part of the reason to want
such a descriptive approach, which is
what I feel like you all did, by deciding
to describe an analytics framework for
ineffability rather than, for example, a
mechanistic explanation, but describing
some evidence.
All of that was just to say pluralism in
what we're approaching that ineffable
space from multiple compressions or bowls
to even describe English words,
scientific models.
And it reminds me of the recent
discussions with Lance Acosta who
described how other discrepancy measures
other than free energy could be used and
that free energy has been used in machine
learning.
The variational auto encoders all kinds
of Bayesian applications because it has a
KL divergence and so it has some
convenient variational optimization
properties as a discrepancy measure, but
it is not the only discrepancy measure.
And you mentioned two in your discussion,
which were the Shannon syntactic sort of
classical information content and then
the Colemagorov, the program.
And so that is like another distance
measure.
So in some ways these spaces can't or
won't or don't even need to collapse
below pluralism of at least several
relatively stabilized kinds.
But I thought that was a very important
point, Guillaume, about explanatory
pluralism and how we can be excited about
one area of science or one way of knowing
and it's compatible with others ways of
knowing because we have some of those
properties of differences that were
discussed.
So those are first thoughts before even
any active technicality.
Guillaume: Go for it.
Eric: Sure.
Xu: No, I just want to remark that KL is
distance between two distributions.
Yeah, anyway.
Guillaume: Yeah, I was just saying in the
case of the autism, this typically show
how also you don't necessarily need to go
to the mechanistic neurobiology to have
potential explanation.
And so in the case of Crabber for
explaining the brain, there's a very nice
definition, very nice mindscape of
different kind of explanation and in the
same way those different formalism can
give different perspective on how to
understand what's going on.
Autism has been very focused on the
neurobiology at some point and the
genetics, but maybe it's not at that
level specifically that the functional
understanding should occur.
I don't say it has a no causal
relationship because it's highly
genetically irritable and so on, but
sometimes the functional understanding is
not necessarily at the very lowest level
of explanation.
Daniel: So now, to kind of move to active
imprints and really physics based
approaches, the trajectory recovery is
going to have some maximum information
representation with the generalized
coordinates of motion.
It's how paths are represented in many
settings.
And so that path of least action, the
Bayesian mechanics on that mindscape,
whatever it is, empirically, it's like
fitting a spline in that space or doing
some other kind of modeling.
Whether it's SPM modeling or hyper
scanning, there's some kind of
generalized time series modeling between
the present and artifacts, the past, the
future, other entities.
Guillaume: What do you mean, Daniel?
I didn't get it.
Daniel: Just that that kind of trajectory
recovery is what is being parameterized
in physics of consciousness type models
or physics of cognition.
Bayesian physics, anything where a
probability distribution has a position,
velocity, acceleration, and so on, it's
being path inferred continuous time
generative models, and there's discrete
time generative models in activ and
hybrid models, just like other Bayesian
graphs.
So in the continuous time setting where
there's a Taylor series expansion, that's
trajectory recovery.
Xu: Yeah, well, I think more generally,
maybe the point is that you could use
Bayesian learning variational inference
to learn a generative model of these
states that we're referring to.
Right.
If you had some kind of data set that
actually represents a sample from, let's
say, the True model, then you could use
variational inference to approximate that
model.
You don't have to, though.
I mean, there are many generative model
techniques in machine learning that don't
fall under variational inference.
Daniel: I'll read a comment and a
question.
So Yashua Bengio writes Guillaume Dumas
idea about trajectories of consecutive
attractors to recover information about
likely trajectories that lead into each
of these attractors that are normally
lost in working memory is very cool.
And then shu.
Eric, any relation between what you
talked about and the compositional
properties of conscious thoughts?
Eric: Yeah, I think so.
In terms of compositionality of conscious
thoughts, I think what Yasha is referring
to now is that our thoughts kind of
compose concepts that we already have.
So it's something like a sentence.
If I think the fat cat, I'm composing
these mental concepts of fat and cat, and
that generates sort of a new experience.
So experiences are always generated from
these building blocks.
And then, similarly, one thing that we
didn't talk so much about is that
conscious experiences, language and
attractors, can also have this shared
compositional structure.
So, like language, it's clear base based
words combined to form new little
phrases, new sentences that have novel
meaning in a systematic way.
How this could happen with attractors is,
well, kind of in the most basic case,
different dimensions in this high
dimensional state space might converge to
different attractors.
And so now one attractor that's converged
to is really a composition of attractors
along different dimensions.
So this is a sense in which our
experiences are compositional.
Our attractors that generate those
experiences can have compositional
structure.
And this could be a reason why language
itself is compositional.
We're basically trying to come up with
some way of describing or identifying
compositions of attractors.
Xu: I mean, I would add that
compositionality is a mechanism for
reducing descriptional complexity.
In fact, that's arguably the objective
for the compositional nature of our
thoughts and language features.
Like less time to describe, more
robustness to noise.
Yeah, I mean, if you're trying to
describe an instance of a state,
obviously the descriptional complexity is
much less if it's built up of concepts
that you already know about.
Eric: Yeah, just to bring this back to
something I mentioned in the talk, I
pointed out that attractors have this
discrete structure.
There's a finite number of them, and we
could assign labels to them.
But if these attractors are
compositional, which would allow for a
richer space, richer number of
attractors, basically it's finite.
But the space of total attractors is
exponentially large.
So we don't want a Lagrange that's
assigning one unique word to every
composition of attractors.
It would be an exponentially large
language.
We want some kind of language that will
minimize the description, like what Shu
said, you could have a language that's
compositional.
Daniel: Yeah, I think that provides a
really.
Eric: I think you're muted Daniel.
Daniel: Sorry.
It provides a very interesting and
justifying rationale for using the
description length as opposed to the Kale
divergence, which is maybe in some
telepathy enabled world or space.
The KL divergence does help you move
quickly or on some defined manifold.
But in encoding decoding space and on the
computers that we have, then writing
shorter programs and or making smaller
information, theoretic compressions
becomes one of the imperatives to take
the kind of empirical approach that you
are describing.
Because though you've described mainly
equations, these are all also computer
packages that can be used to model
different data sets.
So what kinds of data sets do you think
this is most proximally applicable to?
Eric: Yeah.
Are you saying like, what kind of data
sets would kind of minimum description
length computational models be most
useful for.
Daniel: Or just with the approaches and
measures that you described today?
What kinds of data sets or behavioral and
cognitive settings do you think that
could be used as an empirical tool or
measure for?
I think it'd be really interesting to
hear about does the data already exist?
Is it some hypothetical measurement?
Are there ways to even reanalyze?
Yes.
Guillaume or anyone else?
Guillaume: Yeah, I think on language
already there is a lot of things that
have been done on the number of bytes per
second transferred, for instance, and I
guess on large corpus of discussions or
even in clinical settings.
For instance, I'm working on the clinical
alliance between a patient and a
clinician, for instance.
This formalism of ineffability and
information loss would be interesting to
apply to as even a form of biomarker.
I mean.
Even if at the language level, it's not
bio.
And then you can also apply those
information theoretic measurements to
physiological data, movement, neural
data.
So in my lab, we are recording multiple
brains simultaneously.
We can totally try to empirically
approach what we are describing this
paper and show that, for instance, in
certain population that are more
challenged to communicate through
neurodiversity.
So what we discussed earlier, we can
apply the same type of measurements with
information theory instead of just
classical neuroimaging measurements.
So that would be, for instance, empirical
way of dealing with that.
What I'm very interested in would be to
make the relationship between the access
consciousness and the V basically process
and the information loss that you have in
your working memory.
Right now, I feel that no imaging
technology are not at that level of
possibility.
But who knows?
Maybe we're going to have soon the
ability to disentangle that kind of
stuff.
Xu: Oh, yes, the delimitation of what
constitutes working memory in the brain.
I think that's not a settled question,
right?
I mean, there are lots of different
possible approaches.
Eric: Yeah, I mean, it's totally up in
the air.
Classically, in global workspace theory,
they traditionally thought, okay, working
memory is localized to prefrontal
cortex.
Now, the new perspective that's emerging
that maybe working memory is sort of
distributed across the brain, we see kind
of sustained attractor representations
all over the place from this distributed
working memory.
So all these different pieces, what
constitutes x?
What constitutes that working memory
trajectory?
And also what constitutes the
experience?
What's the function that goes from x from
working memory to an experience?
All that is up in the air.
When writing this paper, we had plenty of
discussions about what is the
trajectory?
The whole trajectory conscious is just
the attractor conscious is there kind of
a sense in which both these things are
true.
So, like, Guillaume was talking about
access versus phenomenal consciousness.
Access consciousness refers to what I'm
able to report, whereas phenomenal
consciousness kind of refers more to the
standard definition of what is my
experience like.
So our framework kind of illustrates that
maybe we could unify these things where x
the trajectory is some phenomenal,
experience it's in the moment, whereas
your tractor is really the only thing
you're able to report, remember?
And you must still know that something is
missing between what you're reporting and
what you were actually experiencing
throughout.
Xu: Yeah, in terms of our model, it's
pretty clear, but I think actually
grounding it in empirical data sets is a
challenging question.
The other thing is that colgomer of
complexity is more of a theoretical
measure.
So that that's actually, I think, the
reason why Shannon information is much
more ubiquitous, for example, in machine
learning, because basically, given a
generative model, you can approximate it,
for example, just using Monte Carlo
estimation.
But Kogamov complexity yeah, it would be
much more of an approximation with a much
greater error.
I think if you attempted to approximate
that.
So I guess that would be a potential
concern.
Eric: Yeah.
One advantage of it, if you could measure
the Call Margaret complexity is it would
allow you to kind of measure the
ineffability of an experience on an
individual case.
So, for instance, one thing we spoke
about with theory of mind was that this
complexity of the experience, given the
message, we would think it would be much
higher than an experience given Bob's
experience given the listener's
experience.
Because the listener's brain is doing a
lot of the work of decoding the message
into a similar sort of experience.
So it'd be useful if you could see
something like are there certain types of
experiences where the message is wildly
insufficient?
The comagraph complexity of the
experience given the message is massive.
But actually people do a really good job
inferring the experience and maybe it
would be different in a case of, like,
autism.
Maybe there's some sorts of experiences
that they simply can't reconstruct.
So I think there's some value in trying
to create measures of Kalmakov complexity
to kind of handle these individual
cases.
The issue is it's not really computable.
You can't search through the space of all
possible programs.
But maybe there are kind of ways to get
around this.
For instance, you could sort of
parameterize a program with, I don't
know, a neural network.
Let's say you have a neural network going
from message to some brain scan for an
experience and then maybe the size of
that neural network or the complexity of
the network could be sort of a surrogate
for the complexity of the program.
The shortest program.
Xu: Yeah.
Guillaume: That'S a cool idea.
Daniel: That is really cool.
It reminds me of using adversarial neural
networks which don't have as strong
analytical guarantees as, for example,
cryptography.
But then they kind of converge in being
able to protect or change or modify
information in certain ways.
But you aren't getting the same bounds or
guarantees on the formality.
And that's kind of like the discrete
continuous dialectic.
And so it's important to embody even that
pluralism with respect to state spaces
because if the formalisms in any of these
domains, the formalism for discrete
continuous, they're not always aligned.
And those are definitely the areas that
can be studied.
But for the space of empirical models
that we're talking about as part of even
then methodological pluralism and
science.
But if we're talking about statistical
models, we want to be able to intake the
data at some point.
So it has to have certain properties
which are even looser than the math.
And there's probably a lot that could fit
in this.
And I think it'll be interesting.
Like when you have a hyper scanning
experiment, how do you include the
environment or how do you deal with
different number of sensors or different
types of sensors, different kinds of
action, and report that people might
encode their symbols through all kinds of
accessibility and interface types which I
think returns to Guillaume's point.
So yes, please.
Guillaume: Actually that also reminds me
that there is also a nice empirical
playground associated with what we
discussed is how we can maximize from an
environmental perspective instead of the
biological perspective this information
transfer.
So I'm working for instance with Michael
Lipsheet which is part of Earliest as
well from anthropological standpoint,
humans came out with rituals or cultural
practice to maximize the alignments of
people and those things also are very
important in our society or to reach
consensus and collaborate and so on.
And I guess this can also of issue would
be very important, I mean when we have to
converge on optimal collective dynamics.
Here we are talking with Alice and Bob in
a diadic scale but a nice follow up also
on this work will be at the group level,
how you optimize consensus and
collaboration on group scales strictly
for taxing climate change or social
inequality and very challenging topics of
society.
Xu: Yeah, so actually that touches on a
well, possibly weakness of the simple
model that we use which is that we don't
incorporate any feedback loops.
So we have this very simple
unidirectional model which I think has
advantages as well because it sort of
shows basic principles in a relatively
easy to understand way.
But you're right in that realistically
there's always feedback not just at the
interpersonal level but obviously within
the brain working memory is top down
attention actually.
So that's something that we didn't
address.
Eric: Yeah, it would be really
interesting to sort of unify our work
with the field of pragmatics which is
exactly about this.
It's like given many back and forth steps
in dialogue, how do people come to a
consensus?
And this could also kind of involve the
active inference framework where as a
listener I'm going to ask questions that
are going to try and reduce my
uncertainty about the speaker's state as
much as possible.
Daniel: Awesome, thank you for these
comments.
So in my experience, computer scientists
and those who have empirical data
measurement experience, they know that
you can have different kinds of
behavioral measurements or just columns
in a database.
You could have heart rate and you can
have video data and you kind of have this
like open ended it doesn't need to be
just a matrix that gets multiplied in
this extremely clean way.
And I feel like that leads to a lot of
these very open ended and flexible
approaches which, on one hand address the
different forms and functions and
settings that these kinds of questions
are asked and at the same time are
working, if not to address, at least to
have continuity with classical
discussions on a wide range of topics
like sequence.
Eric: Yeah, the question of not
everything is a vector, not everything is
a matrix.
You could have more complicated data
structures.
That's really interesting and I think
relevance to consciousness.
So it certainly seems like our thoughts,
our experiences have this sort of
symbolic structure in a way you can kind
of think of them as like any thought as
sort of a graph.
I have a couple of concepts in mind maybe
in working memory and I have some idea of
how they relate to each other.
If it's not a graph, it's something like
that, maybe some kind of smooth
representation of a graph.
On the other hand, when you just look at
the brain all you see is neurons, all you
see is distributed high dimensional
neural activity.
So there's this really interesting
question of how you link them together
and I think attractor dynamics are
another interesting avenue for getting
there again, you kind of get a lot of
things, you get these high dimensional
continuous states that you could
represent you get sort of discrete states
that you could represent and they could
compose together.
Yeah, I think there's something there.
Guillaume: To.
Daniel: Kind of extend that point to this
very meta science area of discussion
around pluralism in science that
Guillaume opened the box on when practice
in the behavioral lab, if not much more
broadly, is using structures that have
different column types than certain
kinds.
Markov decision that might have been
taken to be in principle or like
arguments for the superiority, even
contextually of one framework.
Those are just unveiled purely
methodologically as modeler degrees of
freedom.
Like whether you use a generative model
that's continuous time or discrete time,
continuous state space.
Discrete state space, the thermometer
data, how you discretized it, where you
put the thermometer all these broader
factors that kind of instantiate the
experiment and the pipeline.
They're just all embodied and cultured
niche events in a scientific niche, in a
social niche.
And that's a very pragmatic or people
might use other words or like realist or
I don't know what adjective would
describe that take on starting with the
scientific community and formal modeling
and the modeling process as its own
behavior object and then working to have
the empirical practice more general, like
leading the generality open endedness
with practice.
Though that raises so many second order
questions as well.
Guillaume: Yeah, well, we can have also
from a very pragmatic standpoint we need
to have reproducibility so to have those
norms in design of experiment and format
tools makes sense but we need to just
remind ourselves often that they also
constrain our way of thinking.
And typically the history of science show
us how mathematics is guided by the
problems that we have to solve and
speaker.
If we take quantum mechanics it was not
like the formalism was popped out at
first and then quantum physicists use
it.
It was a generative process and a
collaborative effort between
mathematicians and physicists and
interestingly they come up even with two
different formalism that were shown to be
compatible later on.
So it's a nice tales in a way showing how
you can have even a stronger inter
subjective consensus by adopting
different formalisms that then later on
are shown to be compatible and
equivalent.
I have, unfortunately, to leave at some
point to pick up my daughter, but we can
go into category theory and more meta
mathematics to try to show that those
format in the end are potentially
equivalent.
But from a history of science, I think
it's not just about the equivalent.
It's also to have different viewpoints
that confirm each other to make.
Daniel: Our model.
Guillaume: Of the world intersubjectively
stable.
So to say, yeah, I'll give you.
Daniel: A small short closing comment,
Yom, and then we'll talk a little bit
more.
Shoe and Eric, when I first saw some of
your figures for hyper scanning, and
there were nodes that were being
connected with different edges that were
within and among brains, and there was
this one part dimension of my experience
that was like, you can't do that.
They're not connected, but it's a
statistical causal graph.
So they are exactly the same type of
explanation and empirical data
structure.
It's the same exact mutual information,
linear causation, whatever you want to do
in edges and edge in that
representation.
And that's the map territory situation.
They're not the ones that are touching.
And it was just like by seeing two levels
and the way that the representation could
be used, it was approved by example what
it meant at one level.
Guillaume: Yeah, it was hard to publish
at first because I think of that reason.
Daniel: Thank you.
Farewell, Guill.
Guillaume: Yeah, thanks again for the
invitation.
Take care.
Daniel: So what direction would you like
to go?
Or I can read another comment or anyone
else in the live chat in our last
minute.
Okay, let's kind of read last comment
from Yasha wrote, but these attractors
presumably correspond to different
concepts in the same sentence, are not
independently sampled.
Sorry, it's not like verbatim, but what
are these structures in language in terms
of I thought that was a very memorable
thing to say, that words are sequences,
too.
It's like they're modular with respect to
the dictionary, but then even the
phonemes or the writing structures have
their own compositional logic, like a
periodic table, and then there's sub
logics, and then there's just different
uses of different levels of description,
which is why we don't speak the same
language unless we do.
Eric: Yeah, well, directly, I think what
Yasha is referring to is like when you
sample a sentence, I guess, clearly these
are their own discrete things, but you're
not going to be sampling them
independently from each other.
It's like different words will cohere
more or less, and also they'll cohere
more or less.
Given a context, you want to form some
kind of sentence that describes some
context or some observations.
So, yeah, in regards to these
compositional attractors, again, the
simple picture where you have different
attractors converging along different
dimensions, obviously these attractors
are going to affect the convergence of
others.
Right?
So it's not like everything is just
moving independently along different
dimensions.
Xu: Yeah, I mean, simplifying assumption
that we make in our simple computational
model used in the paper is that we hide
sort of dependencies as noise in the
variables to avoid needing to consider
these links explicitly to sort of
highlight the main points about richness
and affordability that we wanted to
make.
But I really liked your point, Daniel,
about how there is sort of the data,
there's the physical reality and then
there's the compositional structure that
is sort of imposed on that.
I mean, it's a model, right?
So it's a modeling assumption that you
make and you have to choose at what level
of abstraction to define that model and
it can feel a bit arbitrary.
Eric: And then you also discussed kind of
well, we all speak different languages.
Yeah.
An interesting question for that in our
work is would that imply that we have
different attractor structures across
different cultures that have different
languages?
Is there an interaction there or are
these just these different languages
equivalent ways of describing the same
state of attractors?
And I think it's somewhere in the middle,
regardless of what language we all have,
I think similar concepts and similar
conscious experiences.
But there's some kind of cases where you
have a word in a given language that
maybe identifies sort of a fundamental
attractor and that's kind of like part of
their conscious vocabulary, I guess.
Whereas regardless of what language we
speak, we'd be able to get in that
conscious state ourselves.
But maybe given our language like the
attractors that you would need to compose
to construct this conscious state would
be a bit more complicated.
You'd need something like a longer
sentence, a longer thought to have the
same sort of experience.
Daniel: Awesome.
Well, one thing that brought to mind was
neural patches on the skin.
Like different parts of the body have
different density of sensory types from
very fine scale touch and action to some
more broader patches like where two
needles you can't determine the
difference between them.
And then that relates to many areas to
kind of development of taste and
differentiability being able to determine
differences.
And then you, of course, use this very
evocative but also grounded dual
representation of the samples that are
discrete and may have compositional
structure with a path that's moving
through them and seeking to embed the
topology of the sample points within an
information geometry, which is the kind
that are actual statistics input.
And then the neural patches are regions
where to one person it's like, yeah, I
drove through New Mexico and to the other
person it's like every inch, they're
having this rich experience.
They know the different stops.
And then I think one last great point
from the presentation was that we could
kind of I'm not exactly sure I said, but
emulate this informational characteristic
and maybe not even have the embodiment
for that to even have consciousness.
Of course, that'll be the debate then.
But the debate used to be much less
sophisticated than that.
And also people took principled stances.
Eric: Yeah, I wasn't totally clear on
that last point that you made.
Daniel: Principled stances on whether
this would be emulating or simulating or
approximating analytical framework for
consciousness, or whether this by
implementing that machine, that it would
be implementing consciousness versus the
kind of linear regression package that
does cognitive modeling that could be
understood in a purely SPM like
framework.
And SPM doesn't take a package
perspective, except maybe implicitly on
whether SPM models generate
consciousness.
Most likely it's easy to say no because
of generalized linear models.
So some people may take an in principle
stance that any description or
simulation, in certain ways, it's all
good.
We're definitely not generating anything
conscious.
It just would purely be a hugely
energetically, expensive, potentially
statistics exercise, which is fine.
Xu: Yeah.
The chain of reasoning of our work, I
suppose, is that if you assume a certain
model of consciousness, then that implies
ineffability as it is understood by
information loss.
But obviously information loss does not
apply, does not imply consciousness, even
though it's an attribute of how
consciousness manifests in humans.
So yeah, I mean, this question of what is
the necessary desidorata to declare
whether a system is conscious or not is
not what we discuss in the paper at all.
I mean, from my perspective as a machine
learning practitioner, it's closer to
what I said in the last slide.
I would like to get the benefits of
consciousness in an artificial model.
And it doesn't matter so much whether the
form that takes is similar to how it
manifests in biological systems or not.
Why should it?
You know, I mean, we don't have the kind
of resources that evolution has had over
over a billion years to optimize for this
model.
So the question is, how do we design
systems that can benefit from, for
example, the generalization and
robustness properties that being very
contractive in processing can give you,
rather than what's the exact definition
of consciousness and how do we replicate
that inner machines?
Because that to me is sort of a very
superficial well, it's a more superficial
problem in that it's looking at the how
and not the why.
Eric: And yeah, I have some thoughts on
this.
Also, jonathan Simon, who's a co author
on our work, he gave a really interesting
presentation recently that I heard, which
is, whatever model of consciousness you
assume, let's say global workspace
theory, there's a minimal model of it
that you could construct.
We could easily construct some kind of
model.
Like, to make this really concrete,
there's a bunch of mini neural networks
that are the sub processes and they're
communicating through some shared Rnn,
let's say.
So you can construct a minimal model like
this, train it on some task, and then if
your viewpoint was that a global
workspace theory with such and such
properties is what generates
consciousness, well, then you'd be forced
to say that your minimal model is
conscious.
And this is in a way, I guess, not
problematic, but sort of counterintuitive
because the model could be doing really
simple things.
It could not even be reporting that it's
having any consciousness at all.
It might not even have language.
It might just be doing something like
solving mnist in a global workspace type
architecture.
Do you really want to say that that thing
is conscious?
Yeah, it is a problem, I think, with most
theories of consciousness.
Maybe one kind of exception in my view is
theories that say we basically have a
representation that we're conscious.
So one canonical example, I guess, is
Michael Graciano's attention schema
theory which basically says our brain
constructs a model of what attention is
doing in the brain.
And that model basically just describes
something that is like experience.
It describes, oh, I'm aware of these
things, they have these properties, I
could report that I'm experiencing these
things.
It's basically a representation, a set of
neural activity in the brain.
And there you don't have the same problem
where you can construct a minimal model
because presumably this representation of
consciousness is really complex.
And then I guess another set of theories
would say that even if you emulate
whatever processes in the brain we think
generate consciousness, the physical
implementation might be really important
over here.
So the example that comes to mind is IIT,
which would say it's basically substrate
dependent in the sense that you could
have the exact same function, the exact
same mechanism implemented in different
ways, like on a computer processor or a
neuromorphic hardware.
And in one case there may or may not be
consciousness, whereas you have the exact
same function in another substrate and
yeah, it is conscious.
So that's, I guess, another class of
theories that would say that emulation
does not necessarily imply that you're
actually generating consciousness.
Daniel: In our last 2 minutes, what are
your closing thoughts or next directions
exhortations to the humans and language
models?
Eric: Yeah, well, I guess I'm interested
in this stuff a lot from a purely
philosophical perspective.
So the hard problem for me is really
salience of why would any physical
mechanisms generate consciousness?
And the nice thing, at least for me about
this work, the most satisfying part of it
was that I initially had this intuition
that experiences what the color red is.
It's not just information, it's kind of
underdetermined there's something more
than just information because I can't do
things like describe it.
But now we have a theory that kind of
breaks that intuition.
And now I have a satisfying explanation,
I feel, for why I can't describe my
experiences but under a physicalist
framework.
So I think it'd be interesting to reason
through some other of the thought
experiments that make the hard problem
salient and kind of develop some models
that kind of break the intuitions.
For the hard problem in my case at least,
I've seen it done in this scenario with
the topic of ineffability.
So there's no reason in principle that it
can't be done across other aspects of the
hard problem.
Xu: Yeah.
So I think if I were to sum up the work
in one very high level sentence, it's
that, well, reasoning subjectively about
subjectivity is very difficult, but
reasoning objectively about subjectivity
is easier.
And that's sort of what we do in the
paper because we take an objective
standpoint and we try to formalize or
characterize subjectivity from that
standpoint.
That sort of makes the picture clearer.
From my perspective, I'm interested in
consciousness mainly in terms of what it
offers what it brings in terms of, for
example, improving generalization of
artificial learned models.
Yeah, it's interesting because another
work that I'm doing is formalizing
generalization bounds for information
bottleneck, which is a regularization
principle used in machine learning.
So it's just really interesting how
evolution has sort of discovered by
itself this this regularizer principle
that that that it applies to to human
cognition that we can also show
mathematically, actually does improve
guarantees on on generalization.
That that is really mind blowing to me.
Daniel: Wow.
Great presentation.
So thank you both for joining you're
welcome back anytime.
Eric: Thanks so much, Daniel.
It was a lot of fun.